cientos de miles de personas han salido
a las calles de Madrid para la
manifestación del orgullo la primera que
se celebra en España tras la aprobación
y entrada en vigor de la ley trans desde
el año pasado ha cambiado mucho he
podido cambiar mi nombre Mi documento Y
eso es muy importante y sean
validado muchas cosas que la verdad
nosotros lo necesitamos en Colombia yo
no puedo salir así libremente a la calle
sin que me griten o me abuche no me
digan algo
tendría que estar nuestra bandera
[Aplausos]
la semana del orgullo se Está celebrando
a la parques terminan de ultimarse los
gobiernos regionales y locales de las
elecciones del 28 de mayo la
ultraderecha ha entrado a gobernar en
más de 140 alcaldías y también en dos
regiones españolas de la mano del
partido de derecha partido popular la
entrada de la extrema derecha a estos
gobiernos y con las perspectivas de
elecciones generales del 23 de Julio
preocupa a la comunidad diversa ella y
yo somos dos generaciones ella tiene 15
años y yo 60 llevo luchando por esto
toda la vida y sinceramente me da
muchísimo resquemor Que vox aparezca en
cualquier sitio porque eso es pisar
nuestros derechos me preocuparía que
fuera una España cerrada pero o sea la
verdad es que creo que creo que no va a
pasar la pancarta de cabecera de la
manifestación del orgullo iba a
reivindicar las diversidades familiares
Pero antes algunos retrocesos de la
comunidad lgbti políticos en estas
últimas semanas Como por ejemplo la
eliminación de la bandera arcoíris y
algunos edificios públicos ahora la
pancarta Lee por nuestros derechos por
nuestras vidas y con orgullo un mensaje
de resistencia en un país en el que el
14% de la población se reconoce como
lgbti